[Applause]
out of the classroom and onto the picket
line today March the 1st of 16 strike
days at schools in Scotland
now teachers in England and Wales are
set to join them with more than 90
voting to walk out in a row over pay
seven days of strikes National and
Regional will start on the 1st of
February one of those will be leaving
the classroom is Frankie a newly
qualified geography teacher from London
if there's better incentives and
benefits offered towards teachers
um you'll find that you'll get better
qualified people who are specifically
qualified for their subjects coming back
to schools it is a tough decision to
make but like anything someone should
look at the bigger picture and think in
the long run who is going to benefit the
most and I think with these strike
actions I think the students will
benefit over a long period of time
around 300 000 members of the National
Education Union were balloted for strike
action it says a five percent rise is
not enough certainly since 2010 it's the
biggest number of the pay rise but when
you talk about the gap between the pay
and inflation it's the biggest Gap so
actually the pay increase this year is
the biggest pay cut that we've had since
2010. the government has called the
walkout unfair if we pay inflation
devices and then baking inflation then
it's not going to help anybody it is
deeply disappointing for parents for
children and it will have an impact
which is not really fair when you
consider all of the disruption that they
had during the pandemic
the Olympus Academy trust in Bristol
manages nine schools with 800 staff and
six and a half thousand pupils they've
already started working on contingency
plans
at the moment we don't know what the
impact will be
we will do our best to carry on
providing education and keep schools
open it's not us who are setting the pay
tariffs they're set nationally therefore
that that's quite a difficulty for us
head teachers in England and Wales will
aim to keep the schools open but it's
clear there is going to be disruption
strike action by teachers comes at a
difficult times schools have only just
really got back into the swing of things
after around two years of disruption
caused by the pandemic and nobody in
classrooms really wants to go back to
online learning but that may be the
reality for parents and school children
in just a few weeks time
think they do an amazing job and if
they're not paid and then they end up
leaving then we're going to have less
teachers overall obviously need to do
homeschooling look after the kids we've
got work to think about
um so I don't know mixed happy at the
same time because I can get my work done
quickly but also like not that happy
because like I won't be able to see my
friends and stuff how would you feel if
you had to do online learning again it's
hard for the parents but it's sometimes
fun for the kids sometimes not because
as I just said you know you can do your
work quickly and play and then play
games
not all ballots resulted in industrial
action votes by head teachers and
support staff in England failed to reach
the strike threshold but the fact is
vast numbers of teachers will begin
walking out next month
this latest public sector Fallout has
now reached the classroom
damn Whitehead Sky News in Bristol